-It's in the cloud.
It's in the cloud. OJ!
It's in the cloud!
-Mm-hmm.
[ Rumbling ]
-Yeah, no, no, no.
Run, OJ, run!
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Growling ]
-Welcome back to "Late Night,"
everybody!
We're here with Jordan Peele.
That was a clip from your
excellent film "Nope."
I saw you last night.
We mentioned your cast.
I've talked to you before,
as a director, as a writer,
you put together so many
elements to make a film.
One of the things that seems
coolest to me is
when you put together
your casts.
And last night, you presented
an award for Keke Palmer.
She won the New York Film
Critics Circle Award
for best actor -- best actress.
-Very prestigious,
very prestigious,
very happy for her.
-And it was lovely. You said
some lovely words about her
and how much
she's given to film.
-She is truly incredible.
It was one of these
performances,
and everybody's amazing in the
film, but one of these things
where you could just feel
the whole crew and cast
could feel something special
was happening.
And she was creating a character
in Emerald Haywood
that we hadn't seen before.
So I was just so happy
to present that to her.
She's a dear friend.
-You've curated a series of
films for --
Let me get the name right.
"The Lost Rider."
There's more to it, right?
-Yes. I believe it's --
-"A Chronicle of
Hollywood Sacrifice."
-Thank you, thank you.
I wrote that, I wrote that.
-So, this is --
You're showing "Nope,"
but you also picked
a bunch of other films.
Are they tied to the inspiration
for "Nope"?
-Yeah, you know, a lot of
people, you know, ask what
"Nope" is about, and trying to
understand the meaning.
It's one of these things where
it's like I feel like if I could
really whittle it down
to two sentences,
I wouldn't have made the movie.
-Yeah.
-But what I could do is sort of
put a bunch of films together
that I think give good context
to what the movie's about.
-And that must be exciting.
And it also must be a little --
especially when -- you know,
it's one thing to tell friends,
"Oh, it was a little bit
of this."
But now you actually put
together a list
and people are gonna go
and be able to see these films.
-It's a crazy list.
-Some of them I know.
"The Wiz," "The Wizard of Oz."
Those make a lot of sense
for me.
"Friday the 13th:
The Final Chapter."
-Yes.
-I can't keep them straight.
Was that one particularly
different for you?
-Yes, well, first of all,
you'll see
there's a few Corey Feldman
movies.
-Yes.
We talked about Corey Feldman
the last time you were here.
-So I have a new friendship
with Corey Feldman.
-Since the last time
you were here?
-Very proud of this.
-It's very exciting.
-Yeah, so he invited me and
my producer to his house.
We went to his house,
which was awesome.
He had memorabilia and stuff.
Sat us down, and he's, you know,
just this cool, you know --
By the way, if you don't know
Corey Feldman, means you --
I mean, first of all,
[bleep] off, you're a kid.
[ Laughter ]
But this is like one of the
greatest teen icons of all time.
-Yeah, that is -- the
heartbreaking thing is realizing
kids don't know someone
you knew as a kid.
Not someone you knew
as an adult.
-But anyway, so, you know, we
visit, and he has this film
that he showed called
"The Birthday."
-Yeah.
-That was unreleased,
and it is -- If you are like
a cinephile who is just into,
like, a complete "what the F did
I just watch" experience,
it is like one of --
it is this treasure.
And so the thing is kind of
leading up to this missing film,
because the movie "Nope" in
itself is
about exploitation and erasure.
And anyway, so I'm very geeked
to have this relationship
with Feldman, and he's going to
be doing the Q&A as well.
-And how was -- He must have
been excited when you told him,
"Hey, this movie you just showed
me at your house,
I want to bring it out,
I want to show it
at this retrospective."
-I think he's thrilled.
-That's great.
And no, he's --
I'm happy to consider him
a friend.
There was a -- I saw, you know,
there was a whole thing where he
was auctioning this -- the ear
that he wore as Teddy
on "Stand by Me," and I guess I
very creepily bought it.
I guess that's --
[ Laughter ]
-You guess? It feels like you
definitely own that now.
-Yeah, but the creep--
I'm saying it out loud.
I realize how creepy it was.
[ Laughter ]
That's not the thing
you should share.
On "Seth Meyers."
-Yeah, you should say,
"I bought a piece of
memorabilia"
and then just leave it at that.
-But at the end of this thing,
I mentioned it to him.
And he was like,
"Wait, you got the ear?"
And I was like, "Yeah."
And he was like --
[ Laughs ]
He was like,
"Man, I'm so glad it was you."
[ Laughter ]
It's great. So we have a bond.
-That's very sweet.
-Very cool.
-That's so cool that you're
doing that retrospective.
Again, I feel like anybody
who hasn't seen
"Nope" should see it.
I've seen it twice.
I feel like there's
so many things
to find with repeat viewings.
It's a wonderful film.
-Thank you.
-And it's always so great
to have you here, buddy.
Congratulations.
Keep coming back.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jordan Peele, everybody.
"Nope" is streaming now on
Peacock.
Go watch it. We'll be right back
with Melissa Rauch.